vous avez vu que dans plusieurs pays
dans le monde pour pousser la population
à la vaccination on fait des cadeaux
parfois on offre un bon chèque
absolument vous avez vu c'est une
solution ah oui c'est une solution en
fait qu'on utilise fréquemment dans
d'autres maladies
bon quand on veut par exemple inciter au
dépistage qu'est ce qu'ils en pensent
des mesures financières ça semble un peu
compliqué mais pourquoi pas après tout à
se dire que on a une espèce de petite
allocation qui pourrait être attribuée à
chaque personne vaccinée avec un schéma
vaccinal complet c'était mesures qui
peuvent qui peuvent être imaginées oui
alors voilà alors c'est vrai que ça
pourrait arriver en france
est ce que vous êtes pour on à fabrice
di vizio qui est avec nous avocat et qui
est spécialiste aussi un voilà de la
question du coït merci d'être avec nous
fabrice et jean michel cohen mérite
médecin nutritionniste on adore bien
entendu qui est beau comme jamais il a
perdu deux kilos et demi celui-ci
pouvoir elle même trois et demi grâce à
moi alors que moi je les ai pris
jean-michel quoi que vous vous pensez
que c'est
c'est une bonne chose ouais c'est une
bonne mesure parce qu'aujourd'hui on a
une partie des gens qui sont négligents
une partie des gens qui sont anti
vaccins une partie des gens qui
s'intéressent pas au sujet une partie
des gens qui sont mal informés mais en
fait on sait pour sortir de cette
histoire il va falloir qu'on vaccine un
maximum si on peut donner une incitation
aux gens à se faire vacciner alors on
récupérera beaucoup plus de vacciner et
plus on a de vacciner plus on a de
chances de s'en sortir deux exemples aux
états unis on est en train de faire ça
ça veut dire qu'on est en train d'offrir
aux gens un repas une pizza etc pour
pouvoir se faire vacciner en israël
ils ont ouvert des centres de
vaccination dans des bars tu te fais
vacciner tu as le droit de boire pendant
la soirée et amusé mais dans ce cas les
enfermer les gens je vais prendre
bon moulinex je suis pas d'accord du
tout c'est pas à prendre un robot
moulinex ça veut dire qu'il ya une
partie des gens je parle par exemple
dans les milieux socio économiques qui
sont pas favorisés il ya des gens qui
savent pas comment faire qui sont pas
incités qui s'en fichent donné 25 euros
commencez à vous dire qu'il ya plein de
jeunes quand il va y avoir la
vaccination il ya plein de jeunes qui
vont passer en sais pas ce qu'ils savent
savent qu'ils sont moins touchés que les
autres
donc il s'en fiche un peu et eux se
seront décontaminateur ça veut dire que
ce sont pas des gens auront c'est
aujourd'hui qu'a moins d'arriver à 80%
de vaccination on aura pas d' immunité
collective donc conclusion ce jour là
vous aurez un covin qui va durer durer
durer et durer alors pas moins division
n'est pas du tout d'accord fabrizio
comme d'hab
alors non c'est les armes et c'est que
d'abord ça marche pas la russie essayait
par exemple la russie s'est pas comment
vacciner les gens parce que concrètement
il ne passe avec 6 n'est pas ce qu'ils
disent c'est une mm conditionnel on sait
pas trop on va attendre un peu
donc elle a dit on va au coeur des
glaces aux enfants c'est le cas on va
offrir c'est mon frère est assez bon
mais n'a pas aux etats unis c'est pas
vrai c est seulement la virginie au
passage deux autres éléments
ça porte un nom ça ça porte un nom ce
que tu dis là ça s'appelle de la
corruption c'est le mot le mot qui
convient à la production première maman
c'est quoi un tibet c'était le cas
j'appelle ça un site à nantua vous des
six attaquants ils sont exactement sa
récitation de lotion des cours
quand quelqu'un ne veut pas faire
quelque chose est fait et que je veux
effectivement qu'il le fasse
qu'est ce que je fais soit je le
contraint fabrice votre métier enfin je
termine êtes avocat ce dernier de tordre
les choses pour gagner un pur non non
non non
non non non et autre chose dans cette
histoire et deux autres choses
importantes
d'abord c'est très intéressant vous avez
dit un truc extrêmement intéressant vous
avez dit pour les milieux socio culturel
défavorisés c'est top
déjà c'est génial j'aime beaucoup cette
idée même beaucoup cette idée que en
gros les pauvres on va les inciter à se
faire vacciner avec 25 ou 30 bal 12e se
termine iata mais je crois pas tu as
réussi un majeur
c'est juste sur ce point je voulais un
truc les mecs comme moi rien à [ __ ] de
voir vincent balle 200 balles 150 balles
j ai rien à [ __ ] merci foot pourquoi
rien à [ __ ] parce que je suis pas 150
balles près donc le même ne pas faire
vacciner le mec qui veut pas se faire
vacciner
concrètement et on va la cité à exercer
sa liberté avec un avantage économique
mais je trouvais sur un dernier
alors gilles verdez où vous êtes
d'accord avec jean ni totalement pour en
plus la serbie est à l'arrêt au niveau
de la vaccination il faut savoir que 25
euros ces 5 % du salaire moyen au
service et très incitatif c'est très
malin c'est intelligent et c'est pas du
tout une contrainte de la corruption
alors c'est une incitation offre d
anneau dans le nez des mixeurs oui aux
etats unis ils offrent des cadeaux
nous avons versé possible à temps
peuvent attiser les gens laisse moi
finir pourquoi on veut vacciner gens pas
seulement pour les protéger mais pour y
noter que ce soit 10 et jeanrichard est
une maladie chaîne il ya deux choses je
veux dire ils étaient deux choses
distinctes
je te pose une question qui est
relativement simple ténue tri sioniste
est ce que demain je doit inciter
financièrement les gens a pas acheté
d'alcool a pas acheté de malbouffe est
ce que je dois inciter financièrement
les gens c'est à dire la première de la
berre c'est à dire que en fait quel est
ce pays et quel est ce monde d'après où
on pense que l'argent devient m on avoue
mis quelques années payer des lycéens
sans quoi c'est la société qu'à salt
gens ces nouveautés le bon tout le monde
est d'accord avec fabrice do with pas eu
d'accord effectivement d'abord en france
on a une très bonne sécurité sociale et
franchement justement des demandes et a
donné 25 euros pour les encourager dans
sa vieille mère vaccinée c'est qu'on a
toujours raté depuis des mois les sujets
dégâts mais si composition des vaccins
18 balles plus 25 balles ça coûte pas un
bras de milliers amplement faut pas
déconner lennon vaccinateurs comme à
chaque fois pour le comédien qui dit non
au voile moi je trouve que c'est une
initiative catastrophique
oui parce que d'abord ça va ça va rendre
les réticents encore plus réticents les
complotistes encore par des juristes aux
etats-unis par exemple au caire il offre
un donut un hamburger et une bière
éventuellement par jour jusqu'à la fin
d'année vous entendez territoire vous
trouvez que c'est une bonne idée noble
et moi je leur offrirai carottes précisé
voici votre chevet le vaccin je ramenais
manhattan j'ai fait ce dernier soit et
des bas mais ils sont les vrais la
pédagogie il faut expliquer aux gens il
faut une action il faut vraiment
regarder la mauricie
regardez il faut garder la honda
vacciner des théoriciens 97 des
touristes en deuil on est des praticiens
de la liberté jean michel jarre c'est ça
de faire cet hiver tous les accès sont
les siennes la liberté là que je suis un
praticien moi on est contre le bâtiment
cerné comme ça moi je suis les deux mois
j'ai un problème d'éthique et al'inverse
on a un bon laboratoire qu'est israël
auxquels israël il ya eu un mort hier
il ya un problème un israël c'est quoi
c'est que pour avoir les militaires et
12 cl d'eau atteint les 75%
c'est ça donc aujourd'hui ils sont en
train de se poser la question parce
qu'ils ont peur que ça reparte a bien
évidemment puisqu'on à 62 % aujourd'hui
ils sont en train de regarder comment
ils peuvent faire pour inciter les gens
à se faire vacciner donc à une vraie
question à se poser
mais c'est vrai moi c'est un problème
d'éthique doit faire 100 dollars
effectivement en virginie où nous 25
euros en serbie kasey kahne et vous
faire l'échangé d'argent ils mettaient
en israël mais comment ils arrivent avec
le problème notre solution mais là vous
allez être contre aussi ces drames de
vaccins ou 10 obligatoire est la
protection nature sans toi ça
juridiquement tu peux pas parce que
c'est une même conditionnelle voilà
voilà dans le français en tout cas
fabrique tout ça et a posé les règles
avec fabrice désolé mais dès le moment
où les gens on ne pas pouvoir voyager
par exemple demain s'ils sont par ici
mais vous allez faire comment ça mais
moi je réponds à la question je réponds
à la question n'est pas contente de vous
dire que sur le temps de l'obligation
aujourd'hui les critères posés par le
conseil et à son obligation vaccinale
sont pas respectées
c'est tout dire après comment vont faire
les gens c'est pas une incitation une
obligation sinon dallas à 1
je suivrai quoi sur les avait pas ce que
tu dis nicolas est ce que vous dites
pardon c'est un incroyable le constat
d'échec
oui ça fait bien que ce qu'on donne pas
un piston les gens sont âgés de 5 ans
vous voyez c'est gratuitement
oui bien sûr ben on peut le faire
moi je pense à l'efficacité
il ya des gens quand il crève un pneu il
pense à faire un procès à l'autoroute
majoré par le pneu mon problème
aujourd'hui c'est d'éviter qu'ils aient
des morts c'est d'éviter que les gens
passent du temps rennais ont gardé et
d'éviter que les mariages exigeante on a
raté 10 et les lamentables ya énormément
de gens qui pensent que ce vaccin il est
dangereux et qui pensent que le
gouvernement vous nous forcer à nous
faire vacciner pardon mais le pire
signal à envoyer ses deux suppléants
s'il vous plaît on voudrait d'abord et
je trouve que de payer des gens c'est un
aveu de propagande
incroyable je trouve que ça infantilise
les gens et le fait de payer je trouve
que c'est encore plus vicieux est grand
que le passeport vaccinale parce qu'on
dit vous ai parlé de vous faire vacciner
grand raid en premier at il aurait
laissé quand on assassine personnes en
réanimation
vous êtes les premiers à pleurer quand
quelqu'un autour de vous sera mal jean
michel et premier appel car ses
adversaires
mais non on va faire de la théorie c'est
que les gens ont fait des prouesses dans
la mer on peut mettre une avant tout
vous dire reste tous ceux qui sont
affectés mais je vous croyais et 50 bien
et si oui est ce que je voudrais donner
la parole stephanie bon voisin qui est
venu à sa maman maintenant je trouve que
je vends cette idée d' incitation et non
pas de corruption on leur laisse le
choix on leur laisse la liberté de
choisir on l'aura ou touchant mais non
on leur impose en leur disant faites
vous vacciner avec une carotte machin
etc
c'est ce qu'en dit que c'était grâce à
ça on se bagarre entre l'immunité
collective ou que je suis un petit peu
naïve mais je me dis que peut-être
vraiment ce sera un imagier collective
l'acce du nom c'est là que du mal c'est
ce que font rien repas de chez ceux qui
ne font rien
il ya un autre problème en fabriquons
pas pris un autre problème qui est quand
même un problème et y brémond fabrique
serre que quand même à quel moment moi
j'ai un problème beaucoup plus grave là
en ce moment parle de tu parles de
contamination jean-michel on a train
d'entasser les bts voilà qui sont mes
clients afin de les entasser géré dans d
autres dans des hangars et après on est
emmerdé que la contamination
il n'y a pas de contamination dans ce
pays elle est où la contamination sans
quoi on n'irait pas enfermer des gens
commencent en version alors je comprends
pas comment est ce qu'il est possible
d'un côté de vouloir inciter des gens à
vacciner mais de l'autre donc là c est l
art des gamins une décrue à l'heure à
noël il ya une gêne chez elle ce que
vous avez vécu les paliers seulement aux
mesures de confinement on est d'accord
avec toi et moi dire elle a raillé à la
vaccination et non une chose
non et non mâcon confine à l'heure
actuelle en afrique ça c'est parce qu'il
sait qu'à pareil on vaccine on va
pouvoir problème c'est que on a comme
argument quand on n'a plus d'arguments
on accepte de choses on utilise des
raccourcis la vaccination va vous sauver
plusieurs or les vrais basque est vrai
sauf que le texas est un état qu'un
minoritaires non vaccinés pour surtout
en situation qui rappelle à notre bon
état grave le deuxième point la suède à
minoritaires vacciner pour une situation
qui est encore meilleure que la nôtre
c'est toujours pas grave mais c'est pas
grave
troisième élément deuxième élément quand
même c'est que sinon on utilise
l'argument de l'émotionnel ça va durer
combien de temps ces conneries alors
entendu bernard montiel qui est quand
même son mot à dire
il n'y a pas que johnny est allé ciani
je voulais dire c'est que est évidemment
la vaccination orale antique dans ces
cas là les objectifs ne seront pas
atteints
et c'est très important parce que par
exemple si joe biden d'un autant de
choses à tout le monde c'est parce que
le 4 juillet il veut vraiment qui est
70% des américains
enfin c'est pareil il ya un plan de
déconfinement si personne ne veut se
faire vacciner
on pourra pas la teinte donc on sera
maintenant je suis les meilleurs sur
johnny
offrez pas ça pas le sujet
oui à 18% mais non non ce sera 80 bien
sûr voilà alors fabrice est tout content
là c'est qu'on arrête de mettre du fric
à toutes les sauces photowatt a raison c
mais t'es pas obligé mais c'est bon quoi
il a raison on en a ras le cul tu
société pour rien